hello everyone and welcome to today's
keynote presentation the invisible
influence of the microbiome presented by
dr. Jack Gilbert we are excited to bring
you this educational and seminar
presented by lab roots for more
information about lab roots please visit
www announcements first this is an
interactive event and we encourage
everyone to submit questions and
comments during the presentation to do
so click on the Q&A button in the lower
left of the presentation window enter
your questions and comments in the Q&A
box that appears on the screen also if
these slides will be presented in this
slide window of the screen and you can
enlarge the slides by clicking on the
enlarged screen button and the lower
right of the screen window finally if
you have any difficulty viewing or
hearing this presentation during the
broadcast please click on the support
button and the upper right of the
presentation window or let us know what
the problem is using the Q&A button on
the lower left with that I'd like
introduce today's speaker dr. Jack
Gilbert dr. Gilbert is currently
applying next-generation sequencing
technologies to micro microbial
metagenomics and meta transcriptomics to
test fundamental hypotheses in microbial
ecology he has authored more than more
than 120 peer-reviewed publications and
book chapters on metagenomics and
approaches to ecosystem ecology dr.
Gilbert is focused on analyzing
microbial function and diversity
community assembly processes and dynamic
interactions between taxa with an aim of
predicting the metabolic output from a
community he is currently working on
generating observational and mechanistic
models of microbial communities natural
urban built and human ecosystems he is
on the board of genomic standards
consortium is a section editor for plus
1 and senior editor for the is ma
journal and environmental microbiology
and his pi/4 the earth micro microbiome
project home microbiome project both
microbial modeling project Hospital
microbiome project and the Chicago River
microbiome project please join me in
welcoming dr. Gilbert to today's
presentation I will now turn the
presentation over to him right hello
everybody it's great to be here my name
is Jack Gilbert and as Bob said I'm
associate professor in the department of
ecology and evolution and partner
surgery university of chicago as well as
being a group leader and microbial
ecology Argonne National Laboratory in a
senior scientist at Marine Biological
Laboratory over of woods hole I am very
excited to be a microbial ecologist in
this day and age it's a it's a fun thing
to do we start to understand that
microbial ecology has a significant role
to play in understanding all of the
aspects of ecology that we see in in
various environments I'm going to be
talking today about the human body but
ostensibly the human body is is no
different to the ocean or soil or a
plant or an animal it's just another
environment another ecosystem that has
been colonized by bacteria and and these
bacteria found ways to adapt and to
interact with the human body in many
intricate pathways you have around 100
trillion bacterial cells in your body
and everyone bands around the number ten
to one in terms of the ten bacterial
cells to receive one human cell but it's
really more like around two to three
times the number of human cells in
bacteria so they weigh around two to
three pounds which is about the same way
your brains they've sent you very
important the vast majority of them
reside inside you've got but even your
skin is intricately integrated into
microbial ecology there are bacteria
from the surface deep down into the sub
layers and they inhabit very very
complicated niches throughout that
system I'm going to be highlighting work
today on helping us to understand how
those bacteria interact with our body
with regards to their interaction with
our neurological behavior through the
immune system our response to food
allergens response to food in general
neurological development and an even our
ability to gain weight and then I'll
finish up by talking about where these
bacteria come from and how we interact
with them in our modern world so I'll
start off by saying we need microbes
they're very important bacteria and
viruses are needed by the body in order
to allow the body and brain to develop
properly in this image we can see a
three different mouse seeker this is a
part of their gut that contains a lot of
the bacteria but one on the far right
the tiny little squiggly one that's a
healthy one and the one on the far left
is none healthy one from a germ-free
mouse or you can call it unhealthy it's
Jerry mouse as long as you don't take it
outside of its bubble is perfectly
healthy but it's biologically very
different from a mouse which has
bacteria associated with it as you can
see that physiology of its cecum is
changed dramatically it's enlarged it's
inflamed the immune system is responding
to the absence of those microorganisms
by altering the development of the
physiology of the mouse and this is
because organisms you mean nice plants
animals they've evolved in a sea of
microbes they never evolved a way to
eradicate or get rid of all those
microorganisms so they've evolved to
deal with them and one of the ways it
vowed to deal with a mr. developing a
complex immune system that helps them to
interact and even utilize those
organisms to develop their physiology
and to interact with the world we
no we need them we think the human
social behavior and the social behavior
of many organisms may have evolved to
allow their propagation between animals
in a fantastic piece of work by from
Duke University tongue hotel they
explored the distribution of
microorganisms through the boom
populations and animals that are
frequently groomed each other were more
likely to share bacteria than animals
that didn't groom each other and this
sharing overrode any different different
response to food intake so diet didn't
significantly have as big an impact as
the ability of those organisms animals
to groom each other and therefore you
know even human behaviors such as
shaking hands or kissing or hugging they
have evolved to propagate the the
distribution of bacteria within a
population of humans it it sounds crazy
but it really isn't that crazy and on
that balance many of our behaviors may
be influenced or may have evolved to
enable us to either avoid bad organisms
or promote the distribution and
acquisition of good organisms which help
our body to respond appropriately to
different environments now when we when
we consider that relationship with
behavior work by Jon cryin for example
has highlighted the extreme importance
of the gut brain axis the relationship
between what happens inside your
intestine and what's going on in your
brain and your behavior and we know that
there are many different mechanisms by
which microorganisms can influence
neurological behavior so for example
bacteria can influence interactions with
the immune system the immune system can
change inflammatory status this can
affect your neurological firing through
the vagus nerve back up into the into
the brain bacteria in the gut may affect
myelination in various parts of the body
and therefore diseases that are a due to
a reduction in the amount of myelination
may be altered by the type of bacteria
that are present and in this particular
study we're showing here crying and many
other
colleagues have have explored the the
role that bacteria in a mouse plays in
its behavior so we know that when you
take a germ-free mouse a mouse without
any bacteria it exhibits the behavior
which is very bizarre for a mouse you
know a mouth should be highly afraid it
should be very anxious of its
environment because the brave mouse that
wanders out gets eaten very quickly in
the anxious mouse that hides away from
predators remains live and breeds and
but when we take bacteria away from a
mouse the mouse becomes very brave it it
reduces the anxiety that Mouse
experiences and in this instance we have
a elevated maze the mouse that's inside
that maze but will come outside of the
box if it doesn't have bacteria and walk
along this elevated platform as if
everything's fine and when it when it
doesn't have when it has bacteria inside
it when it's grown up in a conventional
way the mouse will stay hidden inside
the box and will prefer not to walk
along that platform and that's very
important so the bacteria in the gut can
alter the behavioral abnormalities or
behavioral physiologies of an animal at
very specific level therefore it can do
the same to us we also know that
bacteria can have a big impact upon how
we how we respond to different foods so
problem foods like peanuts and and
shellfish and milk cause many look at 32
million people currently suffer from
these kinds of allergies and they cause
a histamine response and can lead to
hives and massive information and
sometimes anaphylactic shock and so it's
very important for us to understand the
potential role that bacteria could be
playing in the propagation or the all
the substantial reduction in the
prevalence of food allergies we know
from work with Kathleen Adler at the
University of Chicago that adding
Clostridium organisms back into a mouse
model very early in its development can
significantly desensitize that mouse to
peanut allergens so that the mouse will
no longer show a in neurological
response
or inappropriate in the neurological
response to those allergens and this is
very important we're also working with
Kathy we've seen the same thing in cow's
milk with cows milk allergies which
affect a large number of infants and and
people we think that the the abundance
of organisms that can generate short
chain fatty acids such as butyrate can
play a significant role in exacerbating
the desensitization or over
sensitization of infant's human infants
in this case to cow's milk allergens and
so working in this allergic space were
able to explore the role in which
bacteria can play in reducing the
allergic response to specific foods we
believe them that the generation of
short-chain fatty acids are very
important in this instance in that the
short chain fatty acids are feeding
Isana fills and other immune cells
inside the epithelial lining of the
gastrointestinal tract and therefore
feeling back to significantly reduce
inflammatory status Byron I'll 22
response we also know that bacteria can
change the way you sense foods so even
as early as food sensing in the oral
cavity in the oral pharyngeal cavity we
know that for example wine and the way
wine is processed by the saliva and the
bacteria in the saliva can affect the
number of aromatic chemicals that you're
released in the mouth and therefore
taken up into the nose in a study with
danilo collini in University of Naples
were able to demonstrate that a beast
people they had bacterial signatures in
their saliva which seemed to alter the
chemical perception of wine and the
nasal pharyngeal perception of that wine
by reducing the number of aromatic
carbons released during the oral process
and this is important why it's important
important to me but it's also important
because it means that as early as food
intake into the mouth our behavior our
response to these foods is already being
altered already being changed by the
activity of microbes
we also know that we can potentially
alter neurological phenotypes it's a be
controversial to say we can cure autism
we can potentially alleviate autistic
symptoms in mouse models at this stage
but many other symptoms such as
depression and anxiety and and
conditions such as learning ability or
the ability to retain information can be
altered by the presence or absence of
certain types of organisms and
post-surgical depression for example we
can see a significant reduction in the
instance of post-surgical depression
with the application of simple
probiotics such as Greek yogurt now
those studies need to be replicated in a
much more robust than double-blind trial
way in order to determine the absolute
efficacy but it's an interesting lead in
helping us to understand the potential
link between neurological depression and
the microbiome in pioneering work from
Sarkis mazmanian and paul patterson out
at Caltech they demonstrated that the
introduction of a single microorganism
back into an autistic mouse model
actually significantly reduced the
symptoms of autism in that model um and
you know this is by the simple
introduction of a probiotic which moved
the microbiome in that Mouse from a
disordered autistic phenotype to a more
healthy normal phenotype which changed
the level of different metabolites in
the serum of the mouse the blood of the
mouse and therefore potentially altered
the endocrinological in neurological and
neurological behavior and there is hope
to push this work out into clinical
trials in order to test its
effectiveness on humans we also know the
bacteria can trigger other
neurodevelopmental conditions
Parkinson's and Alzheimer's could be
altered by bacterial interaction and
metabolism in the gut and as well as
bacterial metabolites getting into the
bloodstream and the abundance of beta n
my fellow MLL alyline and brain-derived
neurotropic factors and gaba have been
linked to in the serum of patients have
been linked to the onset of outsiders
for example and we are starting to
understand how microbial metabolism may
be affecting the abundance of those
particular metabolites what's very
interesting is that
certain conditions such as Parkinson's
may be triggered by an alteration or
change in the microbiome and if we can
understand that link potentially
mediated through the immune system we
may be able to prevent the onset of
these conditions we know that bacteria
can make you fat as well but this has
been very well publicized through many
research groups around the country one
great study from leaping xiaolin in
Shanghai demonstrated that when a
morbidly obese person goes on a
significant diet in this case a diet of
traditional Chinese whole grains they
they also show a significant shift in
their microbiome in this one instance in
the study with leaping gel the the
individual weighed 385 pounds he lost
113 pounds by eating a diet whole grains
and then this is in about 9 months and
in at the beginning he had in abundance
of a particular organism which was
almost a [ __ ] absent by the end this
organism was in her about two colossi a
b-29 which when introduced back into a
mouse model significantly increases the
likelihood mouse will become obese it's
almost as if the mouse is altering the
microbial abundance of that of that
altering the obesity of that Mouse I had
a question from Mariah vanish Cuba I
have apologized by pronounce your name
wrong can we prevent the onset of autism
with bacteria potentially we can it's an
interesting point the ability to prevent
the onset of a disease is is only
predicated in our understanding of the
onset and many of the autistic phenotype
is is actually due to developmental
regression during development so
neurological pathways I'm not probably
properly formed the development is
[ __ ] during in utero and in early
developmental processes so it may be
that we need to alter the health of the
mother or the microbial profiles of the
mother in order to have any effect
during pregnancy and that could have
reduced the onset we're not sure I'm
being told by the organizers to save
questions for the end of the
presentation I father
um work from Ruth layers demonstrated
that we're able to also maybe affect the
onset of obesity by reducing the
changing the presence of certain
organisms so in Ruth's study with
collaborators in the United Kingdom she
was able to show that monozygotic twins
identical twins actually share more
microbial similarity than dizygotic
twins or normal siblings so the certain
genetic profile there but in her study
they had a beast twins and lean twins
and twin pairs and the lean twin had an
extremely elevated significantly
elevated abundance of certain organisms
that were highly her editable from the
mother such as Christian LA CA and the
introduction of a Christian LA CA into a
stool sample from the beast person
significant reduce the likelihood that
the mouse that ate that stool sample was
able to gain weight so in the study on
the right taking stool from the piece
twin and giving it to a mouse or the
microbiome of that stool not install
itself that'd be gross but giving you
the microbiome of the stall to the mouse
significantly increased weight gain in
the mouse by adding Christina silliman
neuter to that same-store sample they
were able to reduce the likelihood that
the mouse would gain weight so this
significantly this is the opposite to
enter about to class a in leaping gel
study where he demonstrates that the
introduction of inter back to karate
increases weight gain the introduction
that's one organism Krishna seller
minuta might prevent or protect against
waking obviously this is a massive
generalization and a significant
research needs to be done to demonstrate
the potential of these organisms to have
any impact upon waking well what's it
more critical is we still don't
understand much about the functionality
the mechanism by which these organisms
influence it and working with their
eugene chang and my group at university
of chicago studies look at this from the
concept of ecological periodicity what i
mean by that is the change in day/night
cycle of microbes in our guts and how
that can affect our circadian rhythm in
our body we all know when we get jet lag
or when we work nights we feel
neurologically different and
physiologically different in fact people
who are chronically jet-lagged or people
who are suffering from sleep
privation or working nights are more
likely to put on more weight than people
who are not suffering from those
conditions and in work from Eugene Chang
and my laboratory we demonstrated that
an increase in dietary fats and sugars
significantly disrupt the rhythm or the
rhythmicity the daily with Missa tee of
microbes in the intestine and when that
daily rhythmicity that circadian cycle
of microbes in the intestine is altered
it also seems to disrupt the circadian
rhythms are back to of the of genes in
the patek tissues in the liver and also
in the brain which has a significant
impact on altering the amount of weight
gain in in that individual in this case
in mice and rats so changes in the
rhythmicity the day-night all
fluctuations in the ecology are bacteria
in the gut can affect our ability to put
on weight and this may be a significant
mechanism by which microbes alter weight
gain in humans again that still needs to
be proven so when any microbes come from
this is fundamentally interesting we
know microbes can alter our body's
immune response but where do we get them
from in the first place we know from
work with Maria glory Dominguez Bello
and colleagues that the alteration of
the microbe starts very early very young
babies are normally born sterile and and
the first environment they're exposed to
alters the types of bacteria that they
acquire very early in and that
stabilized through their first year of
life if you're born by a vaginal
delivery you look like your mother's
vagina on my provider and you're
colonized by those organisms even in
your gut and if you're born by caesarean
section you acquire microbes from the
skin of the first person you come into
contact with and those microbes colonize
inside your gut and obviously only the
ones that can handle the anaerobic
environment and the pH variants but it's
an important stuffing point and we know
that microbes in breast tissue and
breast milk can have a significant
impact and evidence is mounting that the
the mother may actively recruit bacteria
into the breast milk a draft as a
probiotic in a symbiotically so pre and
probiotic combined together to provide
baby with the right kinds of fats and
carbohydrates and
lipids and bacteria to train its immune
system to respond appropriately as well
as to provide a an appropriate digestive
capability for some of the some of those
milks and sugars and fats that are
inside the body so this is very
important to understand how the mother's
system and the way you're born and the
way you're brought up may affect your
room in logical status it's not the only
component though you know in a study
with Carol Oba our group is looking at
how the experiences you get early in
life may affect your development of
autoimmune conditions and conditions
such as asthma when we look up two
groups in the US the Amish and
Hutterites we see a significant
differentiation Amish groups in our
population of colleagues armage
colleagues in northern Indiana have a
significantly low level of asthma in
less than one percent and this
difference from their Hutterite
colleagues in North Dakota who have a
very similar genetic lineage but those
how to write populations have
significant elevated levels of asthma up
to thirty percent and the average for
the u.s. is between eight and nine
percent and what we believe this is due
to remember all of these people are
vagina ly delivered and they're all
breastfed is an early experiences
experian microbial learning of your
immune system the Amish children are
pretty much brought up interacting with
animals and with the farm environment
and so that they get a very rich
contextual environmental microbial
experience from very very early in life
you know you're bound to your mother
issues milking the cow very early in the
morning you're you're given mucking out
duty sir there's really no play outside
inside the house you were spending a lot
of time on the farm Hutterite children
are not treated this way the in the
Hutterite communes the children and
parents Mother's stay on the in the
house and the Sony the men that are
allowed on the farm to work in that
environment and it alters the profile of
their microbiome because of the
experiences environmental experiences
they have and so it may be that that
plays a role in the development of
asthma in that population of course this
remains to
seen and unproven but it's a it's highly
likely that that environmental
experience plays a significant role and
this a is a very important component of
our research in trying to understand how
our environmental exposure affects our
development of our immune system and our
microbial cells in work with the Alfred
P sloan foundation we performed a study
called the home microbiome project in
this study we looked at people who are
moving home and how their microbiome and
microfiber their home is altered by this
interaction we know that families leave
a microbial signature in their home very
rapidly so the vast majority of the
directionality of the microbial exposure
is from the person into the home
environment and this alters the
microbial in environment in specific
ways so if you bring a baby into this
environment the baby is exposed to the
skin microbiome of the people or the
occupants of that space if you have a
different occupation you have a
different microbiome and this could be
playing a role in development of certain
immune conditions we know that we can
actually use this in forensic angle has
nothing to do with immunology but it's
very interesting that I can tell if a
two people in a space are physically
interacting and you can tell which ones
aren't physically interacting in this
case we had a young couple who lived
together who were physically interacting
and their microbiome was significantly
more similar than their larger who
wasn't physically interacting with them
this is leading to an entire new field
of microbial forensics and in an article
in Time magazine last week we
demonstrated that and it was possible to
identify criminals in a in an
environment the crime scene by looking
at the microbial signatures they've left
behind in that space and we could also
identify significant components of their
of their personal personal life such as
whether they took in the case of this
study where they took migraine medicine
so from the microbial profile they left
behind in the environment we're able to
predict accurately that one of the
criminals suffered from migraines this
is very important because it shows the
potential of these techniques
investigating microbial into
reaction to their environment in other
areas of research we use this
information to map a model microbial
profiles so this is a young family it's
my family and we have two adults and two
children and their feet are microbially
interacting with the floor and their
hands and micro be interacting with
doorknobs and light switches and you can
see in fact nearly everybody's hands
also has interactions to the floor but
this one individual in the second hand
up I can if I can turns that into a
whiteboard yeah so this individual here
and has a significantly greater
microbial interaction with the bedroom
floor this individual of my young son
and so he was crawling around on the
floor and much more physically
interacting with the floor space than
any of his parents here or his elder
brother and that alters he's microbe
with experience so how you behave in an
environment changes the way you
experience that environment this is my
son my elder son micro but he's swapping
himself and you can get your family
involved when you add dogs into an
environment significantly alters that
microbial profile and this is a family
with dogs and you can see that the
complexity of micro black interaction
spaces and the breadth and width of
those interactions to significantly
increase because dogs run around more
inside the home and interact physically
more with other people in fact work from
Rob Knights groupers in University of
California San Diego and university
colorado demonstrated that the
microbiome of people that owned a dog
was significantly more similar than
people who didn't own a dog because the
dog was acting as a conduit to increase
microbial sharing between those people
and this important because dogs are
awesome like actually on the basis of
that research rescued my god captain Bo
Diddley to significantly increase
microbial sharing the house in a totally
unscientific idea that the dog might
improve our microbial profile than that
many peep and proved the immune health
of my family not maybe not entirely
unscientific work has demonstrated that
bacteria prom dogs can protect against
asthma that
in a mouse model and asthmatic symptoms
I mean that particular lactobacillus
from dog feces may play a significant
role in reducing the prevalence of
asthmatic attacks in in this mouse model
and an airport could be the same for
humans I'm very keen to more the
potential to put these microbes back in
your medical records and so that we can
maintain a fundamental understanding of
how your microbiome is is altered and
how it interacts with you through your
daily routine so the only way to do this
really is to either install implants in
our body that monitor the microbial
health of different components of our
body and we're a long way of doing that
effectively although there are there are
methods being developed to achieve that
the other way is to look at your stool
each day and you know the we are in the
process of developing a microbial sensor
which has the potential to monitor
different microbial organisms install
samples as they pass through a toilet
system and groups as far as a wireless
MIT and and New York researchers are
trying to explore the potential of
bacterial microbial signatures in our in
our wastewater systems as potential
indicators of human drug-taking activity
or human health activity in large urban
environments in fact Eric Elms group
from MIT did a great study where they
explore the microbiome of each other to
individual men every day for a year and
you can see immediately in this instance
that the top rope I was significantly
different from the bottom profile this
is because there are two individual
people were two unique micro biomes but
interestingly you can see too weird
instances in this the highlight it again
the up here you see a significant
increase in Proteobacteria at one
particular time point in during the year
and this is when one of the individuals
got food poisoning with salmonella
infection which did actually go away and
they got better they microbial profile
well it looks very similar to what
before there was actually significant
differences between before and after
that the infection and here on this
other individual they got an increase in
Proteobacteria which also includes
Salmonella when they were living in
Bangkok Thailand for a month in the half
and this significantly altered their
microbial profile but interestingly
assume they returned to the US their
microbial profile got significantly more
similar to what it was before huh and so
this is important over the year their
microbial profile is quite stable and
but there are specific instances when it
changes and what if a drug that the
individual number two wanted to take at
this time point was less effective
because of the alteration of his
microbial profile based on where he had
moved to a new drug response maybe
change and that may significantly alter
that person's response to that drug
which will change their health outcomes
so understanding this could have
potential implications for treatment
strategies in a in a pioneering study
we've been doing in a new hospital on
the University of Chicago campus we've
been exploring how the patients and
staff of that hospital environment like
really interact with this space and my
student Simon lacks has been exploring
this to determine when the hospital
became active we've got very lucky we
got a 700 800 million dollar hospital
built on our campus and we were able to
analyze the building before any of the
patients or doctors moved in and look at
the bacteria that are present there and
then look at the bacteria what the
change in the environment and in the
patient when the building became
operational and occupied and so
occupancy in blue and white here we have
microbial profiles from environments
prior to opening and in red we have
microbial profiles from environments
after opening was significantly altered
significantly changed by the presence of
all those people and that that's very
important with we're learning a lot
about the succession of the bacterial
profile in that hospital environment and
what impact that succession could be
having upon the spread of antimicrobial
resistance and and also on the
development of potential health
care-associated infections in that in
ecosystem with the
potential ability to change the hospital
environment to alter it for the better
we've even got into restrooms in in this
is a university is this a Diego State
University and looked at the types of
bacteria which are present in that
restroom and how they change over time
so we can detect how different cleaning
strategies may affect it so at seven
o'clock in the morning in six hot
restrooms in San Diego State University
we went in and be sterilized them for 20
minutes with bleach till there was
nothing there all the organic material
DNA and RNA been completely removed and
then we swapped the surface every hour
for from 8am me barkat up from ATM here
until three o'clock in the afternoon and
we saw significant changes in the
microbial profile over that time and you
can see that the bacteria that
predominantly come from stool are
significantly reduced over that time
frame and the bacteria that come from
skin are significantly increased over
that time frame and that reduction and
increase is due to the successional
change in structure and response of the
communities in that environment we can
see that many of those organisms are
still biologically active and are
responding to the interaction with that
space and if we look at those
environments every day for a week or a
month we see that the microbial profile
every day for a month on average looks
very similar to what happened after
eight hours of microbial succession so
if you don't sterilize these floors they
reach a stable state and that stable
state is potentially has less
gastrointestinal enteric organisms than
it does skin organisms and therefore
could potentially be slightly healthier
but that's to be determined um the soap
and toilet seats however always maintain
a very high level of of stool associated
microorganisms which is probably not
surprising um in collaboration with Rob
night and Jeff leach across and many
other colleagues across the US UK and
Australia we've developed a
international study for American guard
or British gutter Australian gut and
that allows people to
a look at their microbial profile for a
small fee and all of this data then is
made immediately public so that all
researchers around the country and
anyone else can have a look at microbial
profiles from a very large cohort of
people this is important because it
enables us to explore microbial diseases
by credibly associated diseases and in a
very large part of the population by
looking at a small clinical study and
looking at the microbial organisms which
are important for that study I may be
disease-causing or disease protective we
can then go into this large cohort of
five to eight thousand people now and
explore the prevalence of those
organisms across a much larger
population and a population that's told
us about their their disease burden
their diets and their age and their
gender and their lifestyle and that
helps us to explore in a in a data
correlative way the potential
implications of those organisms in a
large population in this instance we
using D genome sequencing we looked at a
husband and a mother and a daughter and
a son in the same family unit and we
assembled the genomes of all of the
organisms present in each one of them
and looked at the color association of
those organisms between the individuals
and the Sun had crippling allergic
reactions and allergenic responses and
he shares a particular coli strain with
his with the his father but not with his
mother or his sister and there are also
other organisms present here which are
highly indicative of the Sun having a
differential microbiome to either his
father his mother or his sister which
could play a role in the onset of these
allergic condition again that needs to
be proven I'll end the presentation
there and I'd be happy to take any
questions I have questions well thank
you dr. Gilbert for that excellent
presentation now it's time for Q&A if
you have a question you'd like to ask
dr. Gilbert now's the time do it to do
so click on the Q&A button in the lower
left of the presentation window and type
your question into the
box that appears on the screen and click
on the send button okay our first
question will answer as many questions
as we have time for orders means that we
have so we'll get started we have one
question right now and that's from Laura
estuary the Universidad CES the question
is in this order we can say that
genetics and micro biomes lead to
metabolic alterations therefore
predisposing to certain diseases
cardiovascular diseases or the first
cause of death worldwide and the result
of many factors among them obesity so is
it possible that cardiovascular disease
can be improved by detecting it failed
and normal microbiome activity and
restoring it so tomorrow night yeah I
have focused on um so this is very
important question Laura it's yes it's
entirely possible and we know the
bacteria in the gut can alter the work
through their own metabolism of food
that we consume can increase the
instance of metabolites which can have
an impact on cardiovascular disease such
as carnitine in in our bloodstream and
therefore by proxy through their
metabolic capabilities Arabs alter it
but it's highly possible that we could
you know improve the detection of the
onset of cardiovascular disease by
looking at how the bacterial community
is changing in individuals so I can see
a point in time when the microbial
profile of individuals would become a a
part of the normal of the apartment of
the normal checkup of people as they go
through their diet they'd stay like
ideally I would like to see it done very
very regularly and therefore put the the
information in the in the hands of
people so they can analyze it more
regularly people something
thank you doctor gallery our next
question is from Lauren regimen the
University of Washington Medical Center
in the example you gave regarding
people's micro biomes being more
similarly living together or went with
the increased contact do you think
bacteria could play a role in why
women's menstruation cycles sync up when
around other women um yeah mom okay so
yes actually it's it's a possibility
there's no evidence to suggest it's a
definite possibility but when we look at
animals who are cohabiting many of their
physiological and neurological processes
tend to sync up around the exact same
time then microbial profiles become more
similar and so it's possible that an
alterations in the microbial profile
could be leading to shifts in the
endocrinological a neurological and
neurological systems in the body which
may lead to a significant significant
similar increase in similarity of those
responses across individuals course for
and the syncing up of menstruation it I
don't know I can't I could hypothesize a
number of mechanisms by which that would
occur and I don't know if any of them
are real but it's always a possibility
our next question from Alberto Mendoza
the Instituto collected me so nacional
i'm not sure i'll read the question as
it stands here and it says I wonder why
daughter has not few interact with
proteobacteria right so this is an
interesting point you know if often we
see and significant increase in
proteobacteria as being a potential
indicator of detrimental or less healthy
in inverted commas microbiome and that's
a very very broad statement but it's
interesting to know
the daughter had no significant
allergies and the son had very crippling
allergies and the mother and father had
very very mild allergies and it the
sun's it has a significant increase in
his proteobacteria concert and now
proteobacteria is like saying you know
is I saying there are lots more sorry
lots more insects in in this ecosystem
that and animals you know mammals it's a
very very very broad definition of many
many many thousands of possible species
so that's why it's very important to get
down to the nitty-gritty and examine the
genotypic diversity of the son and
daughter and determine which of those
organisms are relevant we've started to
do that with that study well thank you
our next question from Maria ivanovska
Medical University of plugged in what
about microbiome and neurological
reactivity and very acute or chronic
stress okay um so I chec to question
seriously one from mohamed el zarate
from emory as well as the me of the
other one the other one is just
disappeared from my time frame oh yeah
so after the one for Maria just now so
what about the microneedle screw
activity under acute or chronic stress
so the cute and chronic stress does
significantly alter microbial profiles
and in the few studies that have been
done we don't know whether it's cause or
effect we believe that the immune system
is it obviously responding to chronic
stress and therefore altering the
ecological environment of the gut and
therefore changing the bacterial
community but it's a positive mechanism
is a dynamic mechanism between those two
components when the microbiome changes
it also changes the immune response so
the numeron force changes it changes the
microbiome so there's has to be a
bi-directional T there that needs to be
understood and chronic and acute stress
are two key components leading to the
onset of depression and anxiety and
therefore understanding of the
triggering mechanisms and the link
between stressful situations alteration
in microbial profile immune response
alterations endocrinological response
operations and then that final tipping
point to a disruption of normal
neurological behavior has to be better
understood and there are many groups
around the u.s. trying to look into that
now the one from Mohammed suggests how
to make use of the HMP unassuming human
microbiome project at the moment and was
the current output of such research have
you looked at the viral Mike comb I
wonder if Mohammed if you're talking
about the hospital study and the output
of it at the moment is helping us to
understand disease spread within a
population and where and to track the
microbial profiles of people as they go
into a hospital as they leave a hospital
so we can determine points at which they
might acquire organisms which could be
detrimental for health and we have
looked at the viral and the mic home but
the those results are interestingly
variable the and so we are exploring
those at the moment Bob do you want me
to just keep going
can't hit well I'm soon everyone can
still hear me sorry a fam next question
is from Russell higbee that the sanofi
pasteur wax design corporation this
question is very well what's a very nice
presentation Jack do you think that
individuals will learn what their
microbiome may contain and knowing their
disease burden familial history it can
alter their own microbiome over the
course of time that would substantially
reduce the risk for any given disease
they wish to avoid absolutely yes I mean
it's another component of your body's
system right meet the bacteria that have
inside us they are integrally associated
with us so by understanding them and how
they change we may be able to alter and
I emphasized may may be able to alter
the onset or the problems of certain
diseases I mean it's very important for
us to be able to understand how how
these what's the mechanism behind these
alterations and changes but as well as
understanding your genotypic history or
familial history or drug history or diet
there's my understanding your your
response to environmental allergens the
microwave is just another component of
information we can use to effect a more
personalized control of arm of our
medical treatment excellent next
question from jun kim of Appolonia
health incorporated in your research has
any evidence of enter microbiota
communication or interaction been found
for example between oral microbiota and
gut microbiota or skin and oral yes yeah
so obviously between oral and guts quite
common of it you know it's tough passes
through
oral cavity in any bacteria washed down
with saliva into the esophageal tract
enters into the GI tract if you can pass
through the stomach acid then it will
obviously enter in and have the
potential to colonize other areas the
gastrointestinal tract but a skin as
well so when when your skin microbiome
is is associated with what's going on
inside you and what's going on inside
your mouth and you know the very active
you're touching your mouth or your lips
with your hand is transferring microbial
signatures and you know obviously we use
our hands to clean ourselves up after
going to the toilet and therefore
there's and there's another route by
which microbial transfer can occur this
is be known for epidemiological studies
for many years as a potential route so
to fecal oral contamination but it's
also root for other organisms which
could be beneficial to transfer around
our body it's just the fact that the
different parts of our body the
different ecosystems the skin and mouth
or armpit versus the nearest all the
vagina the the penis etc have very
different ecosystem properties which
shape the types of organisms which can
bloom there and can stay there our next
question from Maria young the California
Polytechnic State University how
reliable is the database to ide genus
class species did you see many unknown
species in the samples yes so we okay so
if there's a misnomer between our
ability to taxonomically identify
organisms down to the genus and species
level with a high accuracy and our
ability to understand their functions
and we are very very good identifying
the type of general which are present
especially in human microbiome samples
we know a lot about the genotypes of
organisms such a present there and in
many cases especially with the study
that I presented with the family and
American gut we're able to identify
these things down to the strain level so
we know that the different strains of
species which are present in that sample
we don't see a lot of
unknown organisms and you know most of
the time using a 16s ribosomal RNA
strategy we can identify 99.9 percent of
all the organisms if you were to take a
meta-genome of one of these samples and
to try and predict the number of the the
diversity of the species of trying to
identify the idea each of the species
based on their functional genes then
you'd suffer a problem because most of
the function of genes are not well
annotated till you get a lot of unknowns
but at the 16s level and for genotype
level where you have those phylogenetic
markers you can very easily get down to
a very fine taxonomic resolution but yes
you always see some unknown organisms
but mostly they're just relatives of
things that we do know a lot about next
question from John in adame of the
University of Washington what is the
mechanism by which alterations in the
microbial ecology influence immunology
endocrinology and physiology in other
words what are the bugs doing that's a
very big question John but let me give
you an example so we know that microbial
organisms can generate metabolites such
as hydrogen sulfide which have a
significant likelihood of increasing
inflammatory status around those
organisms so they release hydrogen
sulfide that causes inflammation in the
gut and which obviously affects
immunological it is in and of itself an
immune response to stimuli the presence
of those organisms elicits a immune
response for the release of ITA which is
labeling organisms which could be
potentially pathogenic or dangerous but
also keeping organisms structured in the
guts and away from the cells of the gut
lining in keeping them at the surface or
near the surface of the mucosal layer so
there's there's a lot of opportunity for
those organisms to interact directly
with the immune system and therefore
alter the the immune responses around
the rest of the body
for example the by adding certain
organisms back into a rat model we can
actually induce systemic so body-wide
immune responses in the in the rat model
so we can if we can actually if there's
an infection in the liver we can change
bacteria in the intestine which will
alter a elicit and immune response which
is also listed in the liver and then
clears out the infection in the liver so
and this may be a way in which people
microbiome transplants have a
significant role to play in altering
systemic health otherwise our through
changes in the nerve impulses up from
the Vegas tract and that through
cytokine responses so again immune
responses to microbial communities
present in the intestine and also
through the release of microbial
metabolites into the serum which can
implement endocrinological functions
from glands but also through enzyme
degradation rates in in the liver so
there are many many routes by which
things are in connective and that
connection is very important well if
there are no more questions I'd like to
once again thank dr. Gilbert for his
presentation and dr. Gilbert are there
any you have any final comments you'd
like to make so I thank you
for listening and there are some great
questions Thank You shazia for learning
a lot I appreciate the comment and you
know I gave a very very high level
overview of some of the research that's
going on I strongly recommend people who
are interested there are many good
review papers out there to get into
integrate into understanding the various
components and this is a hot topic right
now so in a hot topic comes with a very
specific burden and that burden is
education and understanding of what can
and cannot be done the microbiome is not
the be-all and end-all it's definitely
not the mechanism by which we're going
to save the world but it's a it's a
component of our health which we ignored
for a while and now we're not ignoring
it so it's very important that we we
take that on board and understand it
effectively well thank you once again
dr. Gilbert and thanks to our audience
for a genuine today's presentation I'd
also like the sponsor thank our sponsor
level roots for making days presentation
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing for
six months from today's event you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know in sweb cast will be available
for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that's all
for now thank you for joining us we hope
to see you again soon goodbye